[Music]
in times have changed new Oh submitted
by I'm getting old you know you're not
you shut the [ __ ] up yes the hottest
chat app for teens is Google Docs nobody
showed it no I saw one shut the [ __ ]
are they chatting on Google Docs yeah no
wow these are Android users then first
of all Google Docs is the [ __ ] it is I
love it so for example I don't have any
actual photos to show you but I'll show
you on our JK news
don't let them hack into it well we can
oh so this is our sheets right our
Google Docs sheets that's what it looks
like there is a chat option and it's not
just like sheets for example it could be
like the Google like the word one wow
they do open yes a lot of teens what
they're doing now why cuz it looks like
a piece of [ __ ] no because it looks like
they're actually working oh they do it
at school that's cool that makes sense
that is so smart
that makes all the sense in the world
yeah you know kids are training to be
government employees they're so good
that's the future right there that's
true that is exactly what people do
that's Steve Jobs yep state jobs big
corporations all that let me pretend to
work yeah finish my work in three hours
and then let me pretend to [ __ ] work
I feel like people who work as state
jobs and I don't say feel because I want
to rat people out I have friends who
look at the state and they tell me that
they can get a majority of their work
done in the first half of the day and
the rest of the time that you're saying
they're bullshitting so why waste the
electricity everything else just having
to do their work and pay them the same
and just go that's a lot of it that's
why fire trucks are so shiny to do so
like the captain still out beginner to
do stuff to do so they just keep
polishing the [ __ ] out of everything and
that's dumb too because I think that's
very counterintuitive come down oh you
click on this little circle thing here
and then here's the
option and you can just chat and then
hide it really quick when a teacher
comes by that's so smart
I challenge a set of people who yeah no
one passes notes anymore physical paper
notes sad thing uh yeah but that was
killing the earth all right guys that's
right
what do we do grocery bet what did we do
her what I remember him
- hi chat oh we just talked in front of
the teacher didn't listen to them yeah I
would write notes in a folder or like
letters and then yeah I'm certain ways
like a heart G little arrow or a
football I didn't remember in elementary
school one of my teachers name's mr.
Shiva and then she kept going johnson
johnson john said she was red-faced and
[ __ ] and i couldn't stop doing whatever
i was doing
nothing's changed bro that's [ __ ] her
pony Toshima what it's the same you know
you turn my hair blue from the anger i
mean i elevated your life okay I'm so
sorry I'm sorry do we all laughter three
two because you needed to get angry to
get into that Super Saiyan level so I
made you Super Saiyan me you know drain
take your party recently they asked like
we were playing this game and they were
like Joe makes you stressful or Joe
brings out the most stress in your some
[ __ ] I was just like no Joe's fun he's
the funnest I wouldn't call it stress so
um what cuz you wanted to keep your job
I have such a great time because I
didn't want to let them win and give me
that oh if I say yes and I agreed that
you cheated
I know he's fun no he is fun but it's
cuz I'm the closest to you in distance
yes you are the closest not counting
yes I'm never counting me oh I'm kidding
I'm kidding
your hard pass okay yeah yeah I don't
know it's kind of cool huh technology no
evolved and now we don't have to pass
physical I miss I miss like hiding
things from the teacher though but you
still are SOCAN yeah you still are no
like if you're in a real setting you
gotta hide your phone yeah no no like
when you're at school ya know what
you're not a student anymore you're too
damn old high school student you can you
help me hide other stuff yeah well and
then when you're in college like you're
just losing out on yourself so you feel
like you're just cheating yourself you
don't [ __ ] around in college true
because they did mention that in this
article that this is mainly just a high
school thing yeah by the time they get
to college they they don't do that
anymore yeah cuz what's the point yeah
you're wasting your own money yeah
you're wasting on time your money dang
what if kids had to actually work and
pave money out of their pocket to go to
school maybe we should pay for all a
school cuz I want to treat it different
yeah let me what college there is in the
back of your mind that I [ __ ] this is
gonna be by 30 G's every corner didn't
they do that for public school I mean
not before public school came into play
when they were like when America was Oh
only the rich could afford school right
I don't think that people go to school
to pay for and then all of our youth
would be so uneducated that it would be
a hindrance fer I know even more stupid
than now that's true we need them to
level up they just need to do a better
job at being students I wonder if I went
back to school now if I would get
straight A's back to like high school
with your brain now elementary school
with your brain oh of course you would
that should be so easy take what David
Circle that might be a trick question
though can you show me again do I wish
to mention it what this one that right
there is a spade from a card
thank you next question with this one
this the time with that
I wonder though just because I feel like
when I was a kid I so many distractions
and if I wasn't a as an adult now that
that's not true there's the internet I
just watch porn in class next question
let's go you watch porn and Kylie now
why are you get all horny in there no I
don't have to I'm older now you control
my bonus okay my friend used to
masturbate in class okay oh the little
window net from the [ __ ] yeah and he
always gets in trouble pocket rocket
yeah he has his head like poking out of
his top and he would go like this so
he'll be in a corner like so he'll go
like this and it won't be like that so
he's just being he's like doing this the
whole time like he would whip out his
dick and everyone would be laughing like
we couldn't stop laughing what's wrong
with this child
they teacher didn't say no she would see
she's like what are you doing the manual
what are you doing a manual and we
wouldn't have like an auditorium like
whatever and then him and his friend
they were both like having a rub out
contest like they were sitting together
and rubbing the [ __ ] out of their day
I'm gonna blow first no no you must have
been wrong dude I wonder what those guys
are too now I would love to see you -
yeah immanuel immanuel immanuel immanuel
and I don't use fake names that's his
[Laughter]
[Music]
raccoon or third grade
yeah dude kids already smell enough as
it is and that kids tend suppose like
dick and kid dick [ __ ] jungle gym
chimpanzee like as soon as he discovered
he was a solid she just became she just
got a job as an elementary school
teacher and the first thing she says she
goes why do sixth graders smell so bad
really
yeah they just smell like I have a 5th
grader he's getting there cuz he kinda
is a kind of spirit every time you can
get one from school I'm like you need to
shower now exactly cuz after they come
back from recess or they leave the class
she's sitting there in the class
smelling that [ __ ] I remember one of my
favorite things to do is like we'll play
a basketball or handball whatever we're
drenched and since we're so hot we go
and sit on the plastic chairs and we all
put our shirt over the chair
because it felt so good but everyone did
that and I just imagine all the sweat
that is on that [ __ ] charity yeah
daddy's really nasty we all did that
everyone in everyone did you know I
actually did yeah did you guys have a
ring of [ __ ] like slobber here cuz
you lotta like this and shoot I don't
faze and I did that really yeah I think
I'm making green it was all consecutive
no that's crazy
[Laughter]
my nephews picture he has it too like we
all have these like Oh like yeah and
it's like all soaked and it's all
wrinkled from the teeth marks and you're
like suck on it before like picture day
you're just smiling could you have this
[ __ ] up collar they would either be
that or other kids they would do the
sleeves they'd be like yeah I never did
this leaves align why that's like oh why
y'all beep we God must have been Oh
crazy dude we're probably like
malnutrition elementary school was the
best cuz that's when you could get into
like scuffles and fights and nothing
would really happen there was no real
world consequence yeah it was so kind of
big trouble yeah I mean but we wouldn't
go to jail we would do any of that stuff
do we just really punch someone in the
face and they would separate you you go
to the principal's office and they go
you're you're wrong you're wrong
everybody go away and that's it
everybody go everybody go away I miss
those days
did you guys yes notes in high school no
notes were passed to me ever thanks a
lot okay oh yeah yeah add a board on
that me and my friends had a journal we
could pass back and forth yeah we know
notebook yeah we called it it was the
notebook before the notebook have you
guys ever looked up some of your old
classmates that you had crushes on to
see where they're at in life yeah yeah
so glad that I'm not I didn't get with
them yes I did that a couple months ago
the girl I had a crush on yeah yeah damn
that took a different time you always do
that [ __ ] to us she died and it made me
sad Wow she was so hot when I feel like
what a waste of a good puss
wait uh when were you in love with her
okay
you know what's crazy one of the hottest
girls in junior high and one of the most
flaming dudes that I knew in junior high
so he's saying what's not really famous
Whitney Houston song he's saying that
song in junior high for the talent show
he's Filipino he's black
oh then in high school this fool he
petitioned to join the cheerleading team
and he finally became the only male
cheerleader that Cerritos High School
ever had when I was in college I was
just looking up all people and I found
out the hottest chick and the most flame
and [ __ ] actually got together
no he wasn't gay this whole time this
was the gays [ __ ] man he was
like lips smacking like like all the
time we talked all the time it was like
yeah you guys you already thought he was
gay you had to ask him we all knew he
was gay but then he ended up what do you
know about being gay oh there's
something sometimes she was crazy
like that too that he was like so flamin
but he wasn't he was flaming like
College [ __ ] you want to bet
that he actually might so I know
somebody right now so I mean culturally
speaking if that person came out into
his family he would be disowned yeah but
so that she's his beard basically so so
they've been together since I'm talking
about
well we already assumed that he was but
then the the nail in the coffin was when
he started saying dick pics two dudes
all right so that's yeah so he was
sitting his dick pics like some other so
he's gay for sure it's not it's not
hearsay or anything else once you get a
picture of a dick that you send out to
somebody you're pretty much gay yeah
right but maybe has a good sense of
humor unless it's comedy no it's not
comedy when you send your dick out to a
whole group its comedy to a one
individual figures comedy I feel like
that's not yeah and and so like we more
gets around a small town right but then
we're like oh when he leaves college
whatever he'll he'll come out the closet
and things will be okay but his sister
was so adamant that he wasn't gay even
for her I think it's hard for him to
come out because his sister who's
younger
won't even accept the fact that he might
be sad so that's mean turns out he got
married oh girl that he dated in high
school and I'm like dude he's gay
I think about that [ __ ] because he's
probably like well we're like best
friends and we can probably leave but
then he's still lusting for the dick oh
she's definitely sucking some damn dick
for sure cuz he's because the the guy
that he was sending it to was a kid that
worked at Starbucks and he's gay as hell
he's just gay he straight up as day yeah
he pried all over the place you know so
for shreds you buy or something mm-hmm
or she's his beard I don't even think
we've ever seen him kissed that girl
well that sucks for the girl too because
she might yeah does she know yeah I'm
pretty sure she knows but that girl's a
very interesting situation to if she's a
lesbian in there like maybe you're like
ah you pretend well [ __ ] it let's get
married yeah I just know culturally if
he came out it's like suicide so it's
like it makes me kind of sad but he's
he's definitely up there dude like I'm
talking about like his sister was
defending the fact that he wasn't gay
because he got into this fight after
school at these tennis courts behind
four in high school
wait like gay people don't fist fight
exactly so the arguments dumb enough as
it is but the way she recollected the
the story was way different flashier
buddy outside she goes dude did you see
my brother yesterday dude he was so hard
he came at me like [ __ ] you know he
was like hardest [ __ ] you do all of the
[ __ ] what we saw him was she saw was two
different things this is what happened
dude come he goes oh no yes
he was like [ __ ] like that but how she
saw that how she told us the story was
way way just pull her on so we'll sue a
fool and you guys saw uh-uh
are you serious it was like something
[ __ ] like that you know so it son of oh
no yeah you feel bad for the kid
[Music]